The joe rogan experience.
You can get a hell cat fur used Hellcat like 45 grand.
You know what I mean?
Like 600 bucks a month,
700 bucks a month and you got 700 horsepower.
You hooked me up with one of those when I was in Denver when I was essential to
over read Hellcat a mountains.
I remember that with the astronauts outfit on fast.
Right.
Great.
It's a great car.
Now they have a wider,
have you seen the wider bodywork?
I like that.
It's actually got quite a lot more tire under it.
That was good.
I had a complaint.
It doesn't have that muscle car ass.
I like a car with the wide body.
Hellcat does.
Yeah.
There's something about those fat tires in the rear man,
like as an old school muscle had dork.
That's what you want.
I saw a know moderator,
Matt de Andrea.
No,
he was on Adam Carolla's podcast and card does car guys.
He just posted a picture on Twitter of he saw your old sick fish spotted
somewhere.
That's funny.
It was not in a,
it was not in the,
it was in a bit of a sad state,
honestly.
It wasn't really just,
it was a little tired looking beat up one into the picture.
Yeah.
Someone had,
that's unfortunate.
Yeah.
It was a cool looking car when that thing came out.
That football player,
Reggie,
what's his name?
Bush.
He bought it.
Oh really?
He bought it off.
The guy that I sold it to,
king hasn't been around.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a great looking car that that year,
like all those years,
like 70,
71 those,
those second generation barracudas.
That's a special look and I think a lot of the Hellcat is in that same kind of,
it's pretty close.
It's pretty close.
But I really wish it was the same size.
A Hellcat is 125 or 130% inflated,
overinflated scale version of that.
That's those,
those 70,
71 Kutas,
uh,
are,
are the most valuable muscle cars that there are today.
Those hammy ones,
right.
The hemi Kudos are the rarest and most valuable of the,
of those.
They are the ones that owe me,
uh,
get,
over,
over like a million usually.
That's incredible.
For car,
that was what?
$30,000 new back in [inaudible] 75,000 it was.
It wasn't 5,000 I don't know.
My reverse math doesn't go back that far.
Really?
Let's take a guess.
Let's take guess.
It was like,
I think like five to 6,000 wouldn't be out of the question.
Hammy.
Kuda all right.
The name motor.
Let's go with 8,500 8,500 bucks.
Okay.
You go with 8,500.
What did I say?
30,000 I'm going to re reevaluate.
Think you need to reevaluate for 26 Hemi Cuda I'm going to play a dirty game.
Prices,
right.
I'm going to go right above.
It's Jamie coming in with a dollar fucking assault of winning the show for 26,
four 26 Hemi Cuda.
Which year?
[inaudible] 70 70 yeah.
That's the good year.
Well,
the two years of my favorite year.
70 and 71 71 and the same.
I think [inaudible] 70 one's got four headlights.
Oh seven two yeah.
70 also has the smaller grill face,
like the teeth are small on the front,
which is what I had.
I had a 70 where it's 71 has the full real,
yeah,
yeah.
It's really more aggressive.
I think 71 might be a little bit better looking to be honest with you.
I can't recall if one year is more valuable than the other.
71 I think is probably the best or the results in Jamie window sticker.
Yeah.
34333000430 $3 Oh my God.
The Dalton with Jamie's $1 wouldn't want it.
That's the cause.
Yeah.
Jamie pull up 1971 barracuda knows that is a,
that's my one.
I think my favorite look in any muscle cars in 1971 barracuda.
It's just like this aggressive American.
Yes.
Some,
I mean that is,
that is about as fucking aggressive as a grill can get.
That's got a mouth full of teeth.
It looks like a Barracuda really does that.
It does actually fucking nailed it man.
They were better at at actually,
I think naming things what they looked like back then.
God Damn,
that looks good.
I do still think the corvette stingray looks sting ray ish.
I think that still works a little bit.
Kind of.
Yeah.
That looks like a fucking Barracuda though,
is it?
Does that,
it looks like it's going to get you.
I just found a way for you to spend another million dollars Joe Rogan.
I would never buy one of those.
I don't like I'm,
I'm weird with Shit.
I don't like stock old cars.
What cars they drive like garbage,
but that'd be why zero interest in them.
You got your vent,
right?
Yeah,
but that's like a modified Bob pro touring chassis and all hundred percent.
Yeah.
And it's got a ls one.
Oh,
so it drives it more charged.
Yeah.
It tries like a normal car in the stock.
One of the of that year.
No,
it's not good.
You're lucky guy up the street.
He hates me.
He,
we,
we live in the same block and he's got an original,
he's one of those original guys.
He drives around with a paper boy hat on and drives around the neighborhood.
Said like lawn chair at cars and coffee and play fucking sock hop music.
Fuck those people in his face.
When I told him that it was,
none of it was original except to shell outside.
I go,
it looks original.
It doesn't have a goddamn thing in it.
The inside,
I guess the,
the shape of the dashboards original fuck him.
Well he was just,
I was like,
look man,
I like them to drive like a car.
That works good.
Yeah.
Like why is it bad to upgrade the brakes?
No,
it is not.
You're fine.
But this whole thing that it's somehow or another,
they like doing a disservice to the vehicle by upgrading the brakes.
These people are assholes.
[inaudible] was the peace man.
It's an obstacle.
If you're going on the lawn at Pebble Beach,
you keep it original.
Other than that,
I mean especially,
look you ever,
I mean you,
you love the depths of the Internet.
Look at Los Angeles driving circa 1960 and then Los Angeles driving today.
You know the heat,
the traffic on an old car is not meant to handle that shit.
You want to drive an old car here,
you need to upgrade.
A few things breaks.
When I find out that a dude just drives an old car,
I give him an extra level of respect.
Yeah.
Okay.